[Musique]
on croyait la récréation intervilles
terminée voilà qu elle est requalifiée
ici là de tragédie lors de la joute
entre ancenis loire atlantique et le puy
du fou vendée
larbitre animateurs le monsieur loyal en
somme de l'émission olivier chat biaudos
aurait été d à la victoire de l'équipe
vendéenne
le sentiment général en vendait c'est
que ce divertissement et c'est
impedimenta prête à sourire mais au puy
du fou même on prend plutôt la chose à
coeur je pense que tout s'est passé
normalement au niveau notre équipe au
niveau de l'équipe adverse
maintenant c'est certainement à un
règlement de comptes interne à tf1 un
règlement de comptes interne à la maison
production entre chiabodo s'être
messieurs chef dos et puis à l'équipe de
tf1
maintenant ça c'est totalement en dehors
de du puy-du-fou beaucoup d'avantagés
donc ils ont même ralenti je dirais
pratiquement le jf-17 et mon impression
pour qu'il y ait moins d'écart mais
sinon on avait un écart largement
favorable toute manière dhr lors de
cette rencontre et vous voulez dire que
le jeu a été ralentie en faveur de votre
adversaire à la limite plus tôt c'est ce
que c'est ce que je dirai oui il y avait
tellement 1
un écart très important dès le début du
début de la rencontre que ça plutôt
aisément l'impression en effet et pour
le président du puy du fou c'est jeter
le discrédit sur les puyfolais je ne
peux pas me permettre d'en rester là et
qu à partir de ça et bien en plus de
bonheur personnel dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais surtout l'honneur des plus
folles est des 2600 poulet qui nous ont
suivis depuis ce matin je porterai
plainte contre le canard enchaîné parce
que c'est pas possible qu'on puisse
dénigrer raconter des excuses et
l'expression des conneries entre
guillemets comme ça peut-être qu'il y
avait chez trois doigts flagrant je les
ai vus comme tout le monde mais à qui
s'adresse-t-il je n'en sais rien il faut
savoir que cette émission contre 4
millions de francs perçus par le
producteur que chaque concurrent paie
300 mille francs
et dans le cas du puy du fou c'est 900
me feront ajoutez à cela les entrées et
les sponsors à terville c'est beaucoup
d'argent pour qui la produit mettez
favril toujours d'intervilles peut-être
y at-il là règlement de compte quelque
part dans les étranges une heure
[Musique]